- I'm tellin' everybody,
I'm tellin' everybody
it's harder than Keed Talk To
'Em, I promise, I got songs,
two diss songs who I
had nameless on there.
I promise, I can't wait
for y'all to hear it.
- I can't wait, when can we hear it?
- We can hear it now.
- Let's go.
(TV static noises)
Based on my thesis that
hip hop rules the world,
it's probably a 50 billion
dollar company if you.
(disc scratching)
- What's your thesis?
- Hip hop rules the world.
- Fucking with you bro.
(phone ringing)
("Disrespectful" by Gashi)
- My man.
What's up?
- You did a great job the other night.
- Thank you.
- I appreciate it, I really do.
- Where you want me to sit, right here?
- Anywhere you want.
Man you're all 300 out,
500 for 300 tie too.
- Not as it's all worked out.
- (mumbles) going like anyone,
anyone's like he from got no church.
- [Man] He's still go the Minnesota swag.
- Yeah, fo sho.
- [Man] Yeah, bungle up.
(Lil Keed chuckles)
- What are you in town for, Keed?
- I got two shows and I got a lot of
interviews and shit like WSL, Genius.
- Are you dropping anything?
- I'm definitely gonna drop my album
on my birthday March 16 next month, hard!
(people laughing)
Shit hard, man!
I'm coming hard as never.
- You feel good?
- Hey yeah, how about you?
- So good.
- You just lit at your Super
Bowl party, I seen you.
- [Gary] Crazy, I'm so
sad you had to leave.
- Walk around just saying
let him just turn up.
You lit.
- You did a great job man.
- [Lil Keed] Thank you, thank
you, thank you for having me.
- I really loved it.
- I was glad to be there for real.
- Yeah, so like so many people like
it was just like you know obviously
I appreciate you saying
like just a kind word,
like I have so much love
for you guys that like man,
I'm just really excited
for this album for you.
- I already know.
- It's gonna be so big for you.
- Man, that shit we be,
I'm tryna go diamond.
(Lil Keed whistling)
- It's gonna be really,
it's gonna really go.
(Lil Keed whistling)
I feel it.
- That's crazy.
- Who's on it?
- Offset, I got Offset on there.
Might forget, drop a
little single with Offset.
But they wanted me to drop
it but then I wanted to like.
- Pop too early?
- Yeah, they all wanted to go over name
just cause gonna do they do you feel me?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- But I told them, "They just gonna do
"whatever they want anyway, it's gonna."
- [Gary] Yeah, the
market's gonna do market.
- How does it feel to hear
yourself on the radio, man?
- It feel good like somebody tell me
everyday like they record me,
"Bro, you're on the radio!"
I say, "I know, I'm on the radio, I know.
"What our radio station is that I know."
I know I'm on that but
it feels good though.
I'm obviously makes that shits (mumbles)
it makes me feel so good.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Yeah.
- Crazy right?
- Hell yeah!
- [Gary] The process boy.
- At the blue!
- You know what's crazy though,
it's just the beginning.
- [Lil Keed] Mhmm.
- You're so young.
- I'm only 20 man.
- This is where people get
fucked up a little bit right
like I was talking to
somebody the other day
I was like they're album didn't go
as well as they wanted to.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah.
- And?
- Keep going.
That ain't another word dog.
- I was like drop a fucking mixtape
next week and one song
can change your life.
So get gassed for it but like.
- Brace yourself.
- Like honestly, don't
get too high or too low.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah.
- It's gonna be what it's gonna be.
You could have a song
in there that changes
your life forever or
it just might be solid.
Guys, I know it's gonna be
good, it's gonna be like oh,
I already know just
cause I've listen to it
but like it's not gonna
be like your finished.
It's like people don't understand
how building blocks work.
What you thinking Boyd?
- Nah, I mean I completely agree with you,
we're just talking about he was just
telling us his favorite
song it's something
called Oh My God, can't wait to hear it.
- Yeah, you gotta hear that motherfucka.
Nah, you got my album, I
said the name in my album.
- By the way, that was the
smartest shit you ever did.
The amount of work I'm
gonna do to make that song
the biggest song in the world.
- [Lil Keed] Fear of God.
I call it fear of God.
- Easiest thing right
now for an artist to do
is to reference me
because I will spend all
my money and time to
try to make that song.
(Boyd laughing)
- That shit hard.
- That is the current hack.
Yeah, when we were in studio.
- It's gonna be a big ass album, man.
That shit gonna be crazy like
I really like took time on
all these songs I put on there.
- And where, so I know
you're performing a bunch now
and watching and then what you
gonna do when it comes out?
Just the same, like you just
gonna stay the course right?
- Yeah, I'm still doing, do
everything I've been doing.
- The tour with Trippie is great,
sign up everything you wanted to and
then as soon as he drops all like he,
kid works, we just got
done talking about it like
that's what separates everybody.
- Hard work, man, dedication.
- Honestly, that's so right.
- That's all you need.
It's gonna, I (mumbles) self, man.
Our shit is, I did we chilling,
Everything just come up,
everyday is something new.
I just be chilling, good ideas.
- You're just working.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah, I'm working.
- He was in a studio
with Uzi Vert last night
and he's not even bragging about it like.
- Hell nah.
(people laughing)
- He got that out of the system already.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah.
- That's what it is, the first
time you're fucking lit up!
You can't believe it happened.
- (mumbles) telling me get on the song,
he woke me up, I was
sleeping in the studio,
he woke me up like get on this.
Man, I'm scared as hell, I weren't scared,
I was nervous like now.
Like he was already doing the song like
he could just been bounce
and down at (mumbles).
He opened like another.
- [Gary] You and Thug?
- We got like 30 songs.
- I know you guys, and
what, like the first time,
that was the first time you did it?
- The first time we ever did it then.
- And what you were already like
spending some time together?
- Yeah, we already spent
time together but he just,
I never recorded with him.
I just see him record like
in there just chilling.
He woke me up (mumbles) like get on this,
I'm actually on a deep
sleep, he woke me up,
get on this.
I'm like damn and then everyone,
it weren't even that many folks in there,
it was just me, him, engineer
and couple of my partners
so I'm on debt, I was nervous like I
don't wanna say no lame shit.
- [Gary] Of course.
- I'll think about like, I'll do me.
This shit hard.
That shit hard, so now
every time I do a song,
I pop my shit or anybody, any rebel,
come wanna do a song, I'm popping it, man.
He told I was gonna do it too,
he was like "You gonna pop
it, you gonna pop it on 'em."
He told me, so I'm here to
pop this shit every way.
- Thug's done a real
good job, he really has.
I really like the way he's done it.
How many songs you putting out?
- I think I did like 14, 15.
15 I think though.
Yachty on there.
- [Boyd] Yachty's on there?
Yeah, what Yachty (mumbles)
got that was crazy bro.
- Yeah, now I never did anything for,
I only did like a little,
man, that shit will pay,
I'm like there looking around
where you bring we out,
cause I was back stage, I
didn't see the whole thing.
So the it's your turn, come on, come on.
They racing me, I get up
there, they give me the mic.
Cause I went brand sweaty out,
my favorite artist, they
drop (mumbles), I came out.
I look and I said, "What the fuck,
"it's some mean folks out here."
But then, at the time moment,
I had to handle my business.
- You know the best part of performing,
I'm sure you feel like I
assume this is how you feel,
I was thinking about this the other day,
actually I was thinking
about it at the party
watching the three of you perform,
I'm like man, that's why
I like speaking so much
whether it's 38 people in
the crowd or 40 thousand,
and I've done both, it
actually feels the same.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Does that make sense?
Because I don't want to suck.
Like sure you feel the
difference of energy,
like when you really have big crowds,
I remember when I gave this one talk,
it might have been like
20 thousand people.
When you say something funny,
like the way I do my shit,
and the laughs take a minute
to come from the back.
(people laughing)
Like it waves, but like once you go on,
if it's 38 or 38 thousand,
it's the same shit.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah, you
still the same person.
- Don't you feel like that?
- [Lil Keed] Yeah, for sure.
- One person like to your point.
- They all the same as
I, they see this shit.
I mean I used to be I gotta
have me some shades ever before
I first started like
- Oh, have shades on?
- [Lil Keed] No it's crazy, I've been like
I'd be preparing myself and shit like
my momma had a mirror in the hallway,
I just put headphones,
I'd just throw music
just dance to the music like I'm rapping.
So now, when I start getting on stage,
it's too big to me
cause I'm been doing it.
It's like I've prepared
myself for this shit already.
I've been preparing my
shit, I've been preparing.
- Anything we can do?
- [Man] I mean you guys
have been awesome already,
I think anything like, I think one thing
me and him talk about, just before like
be the young kids so that the
entrepreneur thing is a thing,
but like how can we be in commercials?
Like how can we get our music?
Like how can we use placements?
How can we get things that
kids in his generation
and kids that on this level
haven't quite got to yet?
Like not just to get there
but the building steps to
how to get there.
- I got some ideas, you saw
we try to do you know, I know
how the whole thing went with
Super Bowl, it's all great.
Like it's gonna happen.
The fact that we even got
that close, think about that.
Like the fact that we
almost had that pulled off.
- We almost hadn't pulled it off too, man.
- I couldn't believe it,
when I was like, crazy.
- [Lil Keed] They showed it, did it.
- Yeah, but yeah, they showed it but
we were that close so the best part for me
about that experience
was you guys know that
I wanna help to make it happen.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah fo sho, you here man.
You family, man.
(people laughing)
- So I always talk, I'm sure
you watch enough of my content.
Like the good Charlotte
bit like that's what it is.
You get the right hook, by the way,
and I did this for Saba, I
did this with the Ferg thing.
Like straight up, a hundred percent,
the song where he's
talking about calling me,
getting advice, that little part,
I'm gonna listen to it a couple times and
I'm gonna use that as the pre-roll
to all my YouTube videos for like a month.
- [Man] Fire.
- Like how Gary Vee, I know
you'll give me advices about it.
(people laughing)
- [Boyd] That song is hard, man.
- That shit hard as fuck.
That's some new wave,
it's not the same wave,
it's not even your wave,
it's a whole another wave.
That song wavy, man.
- [Man] When you buy the
Jets like halftime verse
the Vikings so I can go watch my team.
- When my Jets are in the Super Bowl,
I'll push real heavy for the
NFL to have this man perform.
(people laughing)
- That was a boring game, to be honest.
- It ended the worst, I
hate the fucking Patriots.
- Yeah it's crazy, man, (mumbles).
- You need to make a song
called I hate the Patriots.
That shit would go.
- My manager gonna tell me, (mumbles).
"When we get to Boston man,
"we need to wear like Patriots jerseys."
I'm not gonna wear no
fucking Patriots jersey,
I'm a blend.
They beat us in the fucking
Super Bowl, what do I put on.
- And ripped your heart
out, there's 28 to three,
or 27 or whatever the fuck it was.
- Yeah, 27 to three, they came
all the way back and beat us.
- What, I didn't even finish
watching this shit till three?
- No, no, the Super Bowl against Atlanta.
- I didn't know that.
- Three years ago, four years ago.
Three years ago.
- Greatest comeback in Super Bowl history.
- They came all the way, he came out,
Brady came out (mumbles).
- I didn't say that, fourth quarter.
- (mumbles) we always do
that in the regular season,
they'll be (mumbles) somebody
come all the way back,
it'll be a close game they
went by the three point.
(mumbles) kick like a
motherfucka, they just,
I don't know brother,
they just stood that shit.
Man, Bryan couldn't pull it off this time.
They came all the way
back, what the F bruh.
Everybody mad, that's a lot of money
that got lost right there bruh.
- Keed, what about
producers on this album?
- I got Goose, I got new
guy Jetson, he's hard.
That's who produced Oh My God,
the track I told you about.
A song on there called
Inhale Exhale, hard.
- You making music with Richie?
- Yeah, Richie was on
last Friday, Richie Souf.
- Oh Richie Souf, yeah, that's my boy.
I gotta go listen to, I gotta
go all look into like beats
and see who made them cause I don't really
know off the top of my head
but I know Pyrex, ever heard of Pyrex?
Yeah, he produced the song
we made with Money Man.
- You met Pyrex, he was
in the music studio,
when we were in the studio with (mumbles),
he's managed by Keith.
- Oh, I know who you're talking about.
- Yeah, he produced this song,
man, Money Man got that (mumbles).
He produced that beat, yeah.
- This producer is talented, man.
- Yeah, Richie said tell you what's up.
- Yeah, I've seen him at the party,
at your party, he was there.
- [Gary] I love fucking Richie.
- Yeah, he want to put a tape together but
Metro Boomin just send
me some shit but it's too
late cause I already got
my tape turned in and shit.
- Fucking Metro, that's
my man, love that dude.
- We're gonna do a tape together.
- You should definitely
do a tape together.
- He sent me like 10 beats,
I'm gonna do all of them.
Just get them out the way.
I'm already working on my new tape.
- [Gary] You should.
Make fucking music when you feel it.
- [Lil Keed] Yeah.
- As often as possible.
- Though I don't wanna just
burn myself out of this.
I might make two songs just listen
to music the rest of the night.
- I get it.
- Sometimes I got there just listen
to music don't record nothing.
I don't want to burn myself out.
- Gotit's doing good.
I just told him, we're just
talking about your brother.
- Yeah Lil Gotit, yeah man, he's
oh he's probably in LA
right now, he went in.
- He so happy he got
his fucking blue cheque?
- Yes, man.
Gotit, he keeps calling me, I'm like,
"Bruh I see it, I promise I see it."
- I fuck with (mumbles) I was telling him,
make it happen every day.
I said, "Motherfucker,
you've been bothering me
"for three months, now you got it,
"you didn't say thank you?"
Punch Gotit, next time I see him.
(people laughing)
I love that kid.
- Yeah, he, he just goes
viral off of his interviews.
- He's great, he's great.
- He go viral off interviews all the time,
like he just, he want
everything to come like this.
- Yeah, he's impatient.
- I'm tell him like you just chill bro.
- Well, it's double hard
because what's happening.
- [Lil Keed] He looking at me!
- Was just gonna say,
he's impatient to begin
with because even when I was
with him I was like fuck,
I was trying to tell him like
slow it down a little bit
but then just the natural
fact of what's happening
with you right now, that's gonna
compound, that's just life.
- Yeah, that's my little
brother, I raised him.
- I understand, he's not
wrong, it's just, it's just
you can't let that shit take over.
- [Lil Keed] I tell every
dollar get it's time, man.
- A hundred thousand percent.
He's gonna have his moment.
- He might make a song tonight,
it can go, you might
even put a snippet on it,
that's how I know what song gonna be hard.
I put namers on my Instagram,
I'll (mumbles) like they
gave me a (mumbles),
like well nobody using (mumbles),
that shit been out so I
was like my (mumbles),
like that shit been out.
One day I just got up go like man,
I'm a just I downloaded on my phone,
I did a little video too I put it up,
that motherfucker went viral.
Everybody know what drop this song,
they start screen recording it,
I started doing it for each
one of my little songs,
I'd wake up in the morning early morning,
it might be a (mumbles)
I just pick this song,
I always pick the right song.
- Keed, you doing anything on TikTok yet?
- No I haven't did nothing on it.
- Do you know what that is?
- I've never heard of it.
- Alright, so I've got an actually,
I got a really good piece of advice.
There's an app called TikTok.
- It used to be Musical.ly.
- I'm telling you right now,
I think it's the number one
opportunity for you right now.
It's eight to 12, it's
like seven to 12 year olds.
- [Lil Keed] That's crazy.
- I think you should download it,
I think you should put
out content on there.
I think you could become
the biggest rapper
to everyone of them
which will really matter.
- I'm gonna download it tonight.
- [Gary] I believe you.
- Before I leave here, when I
leave here I'll download it.
- Cause I know you work.
I know, cause you work.
I couldn't agree with you more
cause I've been watching
you for a minute now like,
it's just so obvious like it's so funny,
it's the same shit with,
I've been making content for 10 years.
(Lil Keed laughing)
You know, like it's work.
Because because if you're good enough,
you're just that song away,
but you gotta give yourself the at bats.
Too many people give up.
- [Man] Facts.
- Yeah, here he is, you
already got a song on the radio
but your next project
might be the one to turn
you all the way up.
- Yeah, maybe I just so,
I'm happy about your project
but I know it's a just a chill.
- [Gary] Just part of the process,
part of the process, part of the process.
- And I just dropped Keed
Talk To 'Em, ain't even,
but I'm a drop another one, an album.
Go hard, it's gonna be,
I'm tellin' everybody,
I'm tellin' everybody it's harder
than Keed Talk To 'Em,
I promise, I got songs,
two diss songs who I
had nameless on there.
I promise, I can't for y'all to hear it.
- I can't wait, when can we hear it?
- We can hear it now.
- Let's go.
- [Gary] Give me something.
- Where do I connect to or you
wanna hear it just the phone?
- [Gary] That's fine.
- This the Oh My God song,
I'm telling you about it, it's crazy, man.
- Do you want us to blur this part out?
- [Man] Nah.
- Nah, you don't have to do it,
shit's gonna drop anyway.
(people laughing)
("Oh My God" by Lil Keed)
- Ah, I love that transition.
- Oh, yeah!
- That's really good.
- Man's in trouble.
- [Woman] (mumbles).
- I don't think I did too much
cussing in that song, man.
I this time I didn't want to cuss.
And better here.
I write through it, it's hard.
I got (mumbles) in there too.
- Okay, let's me see.
Fuck, that's a great song man.
- What I'm telling you
about, let me show you.
- I'm waiting for you to
reference pineapple Fanta.
- Pineapple Fanta?
- Yeah, the amount of people drinking
pineapple Fanta right now, you see it?
Right?
I'm gonna get you that drink.
- [Boyd] You know every single type, man.
- (mumbles).
(hip hop music)
- [Boyd] (mumbles).
This man knows everything,
he'll just text me about things that
are going on in the internet
and I'm like I'm don't know.
- This guy's had, he's smart as hell, man.
- Ah.
- [Boyd] This song is hard bro.
- Gotta love it.
(hip hop music)
I made it fast, ask him, he was out there.
- Yeah.
- I made it fast like this.
- Some of the best ones
just how it happens.
- That's how it happened.
- [Man] (mumbles) because
you know you're gonna pop,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- [Boyd] That's the best part,
you've been there so early on him.
- [Man] Yeah, for real.
- I like what you're talking about, man.
I really do, I think it fucking matters.
- Yeah, everything I say matters
man, I'm telling real life.
(hip hop music)
- (mumbles).
- ♪ Ride for you ♪
This is got to wait.
- (mumbles).
- [Boyd] You know, this turns
out, you gonna pop (mumbles).
(people laughing)
- [Man] There you go.
- (mumbles).
- Yeah, I was right there.
- [Man] (mumbles).
- Hey man, he got it figured out.
- I'm ready.
We have so much footage together.
We got, we got the footage when he did it.
We were in the studio, we got the party.
We got this, we got footage (mumbles).
This song is gonna do really well.
- I got one more, it's
called Ride Wit You.
Girl, for girls.
(Lil Keed whistling)
I know how to make them
(mumbles), with the girl.
- Heart throbbing.
- This harder than fucking
nightmares bro I'm tellin' you, I feel it.
("Ride Wit You" by Lil Keed)
- That's a great start.
- (mumbles).
- All three of them
songs are in the album.
(Lil Keed whistling)
When I went through there,
I just had to keep it.
I was like this, it's all like this,
but I (mumbles), shit.
I didn't show you that song.
- I just got motivated, I gotta bounce but
let's take a quick photo but,
but,
but I'm not giving up on the concept,
I just need to feel inspired, I think
Tee Grizzley and Keed about work.
(camera shuttering)
Oh, smart, hold this one up,
this real smart, this my
next shoe that's coming out.
- Tay-yah.
(camera shuttering)
- Beauty.
Yeah bruh, let's get one.
- These hard.
- I'll send you a bunch.
- Yeah I need one.
- Oh, it's done.
- I'm a wear one on tour.
- Fresh right?
- Yeah, I need them.
- It's done.
I love you, man.
- I love you too.
- I'm always down for you,
you know let's get in here,
let's get a group shot.
Hey guys, thank you so much for
watching my Facebook videos,
it means the world to me,
something that means even
more to the world to me,
the universe to me, is Empathy Wines.
A project that's been manifesting
since I was a teenager,
I finally have my own winery,
I finally can achieve my big goal of
making a 40 dollar wine for 20 bucks.
And I'm asking you
right now to support it.
If you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all or have clients
or any other reason to
give away wine as gifts,
please go to EmpathyWines.com right now
and support me with a subscription of
a three, a six or a case subscription.
You will not be disappointed and
it would be so so much to me.
(upbeat electronic music)